48 hours is investigating the wrongful
conviction of a Missouri man you've
heard part of this story before in
February Lamar Johnson was exonerated
for a murder he didn't commit he had
spent nearly three decades in prison
after a witness picked him out of a
police lineup That witness Greg elking
says he was pressured by law enforcement
Aaron Moriarty has been covering this
case since 2021 and for this week's 48
Hours she spoke with elking for the
first time here's an early look at her
report Why didn't
what kept Lamar Johnson going during his
final days in prison was the hope that
he would be set free in time to walk his
youngest daughter Kiara down the aisle
at her wedding in April 2023 that dream
came true
[Music]
we're in a St Louis courtroom a judge
set that dream in motion when he
overturned Johnson's murder conviction
after 28 years behind bars he was more
than a free man Lamar Johnson had been
exonerated for the murder of his friend
Marcus Boyd I am a free man an
exonerated man and a blessed man
Johnson had been fighting to clear his
name since 1995 when he was convicted
largely on the word of this man Greg
Elgin had identified him as one of the
shooters who took Boyd's life as he sat
on his front porch these guys they had
completely dark clothing and they had
masks on could you really identify these
men no I couldn't identify him yet Elkin
says he was pressured by investigators
to identify Lamar Johnson after he was
told Johnson was dangerous and that his
own life could be in danger Elkin became
the star witness at trial did it occur
to you that you might have put an
innocent man yes Behind Bars without a
doubt because
I lied on the testimony why didn't you
tell somebody why didn't you say I think
nobody talks to me nobody who am I going
to tell but years later he sent this
letter to a clergyman admitting he had
lied that admission in part would launch
an investigation by St Louis circuit
attorney Kimberly Gardner and lead to
Johnson's Freedom it's devastating for
me that this man has spent 28 years in
prison for a crime he did not commit
foreign
already joins us now Aaron good morning
I think it's devastating for anybody who
believes in law and Justice to hear that
somebody who's wrongly convicted for 28
years and that the person who put him
there uh was pressured to do so
according to him anyway well yes and I
mean it's it was eye-opening for me
um it took a lot to get him to sit down
because he didn't want to admit publicly
but then when he finally did the right
thing last December and testified for
Lamar I think he wanted to explain why
yeah
um in part as as you don't know why he
lied at 28 years and you know that that
man is innocent he's sitting behind bar
how do you live with yourself with that
information well and he says he had a
very difficult time but think back then
he's the only eyewitness he sees his
friend get shot executed really yeah he
tells the police over and over again
this is his story that he didn't see a
face and he tells me that today he has
no idea who those two guys were and the
police doesn't say hey this we know who
it is right at least that's his story
the detective deny that and that your
life could be in danger but what was
chilling for me is that alkene admitted
to me in the interview that he never
really looked at him until he was about
to point him out at trial and then he
realized that Lamar was lighter skinned
than the guys he saw and that's why I
said why didn't why didn't you tell
somebody and he he had been you know in
the witness protection program they gave
him was he paid oh yeah he got cash
um he had his outstanding warrants
clears it probably is so it's not black
and white I mean literally it's just and
that's what was so interesting about
interviewing him but I'm still thinking
about Lamar Johnson
absolutely absolutely wow all right
Aaron Moriarty thank you very much you
can see Aaron's full report Lamar
Johnson standing in truth on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 Central right
here on CBS and Paramount plus they're
going to want to tune in we'll be right
back